I've heard you have a celebrity boxing
match coming up in September when the
Hydra kids hide your wife guy from
YouTube right
antoine dodson yeah I was just seeing
the passion he needs a guy who says like
hide your kids hide your wife he kind of
looks like a heroin version of RuPaul
the our neutrality trash-talking that's
good stuff I'll just be nice I'm not
even trying to be rude you got talked
into the building yeah okay that's what
he looks like
are you gonna kick the [ __ ] out of him
do you think I don't know if I'm allowed
to feel the reveal details I just know
I'm fine can you fight have you ever
have you fly I haven't ever taken boxing
but I yeah I mean I could I could do
pretty good for myself
yeah sure are you training no I don't
need to train is this a fixed fight no
I'm sure it's not a fix right no ask
Anthony I don't know if I should know
it's not a fixed fight it's a real fight
so what do you think you should train
muscle mania is not fixed you wanna
train oh my god I just want to smack
with me so goddamn ugly
no offense so he's gonna lose script it
in there to win this one do we know yet
you want me to spoil that it just boil
how did you I mean I want to know ask
him who's gonna win you know I would
think that they'll probably script our
friend here to win
I think Antoine is a little bit
yesterday's news Chris the bagel guy is
today's news right I think I think the
fixes in for Chris the bagel guy that's
what I think what are you doing this
fuzzy garden where it's somebody's
garden I think it's in Jersey to
Atlantic City oh it isn't late chris is
giving you he's giving you the
information yeah landing city so yeah
subscribe to ass Facebook but you know
all that stuff Instagram Chris bagel
boss Morgan and yeah I'm finding uh in
Atlantic City September 7th at the
showboat hotel
alright so lose your place go to act
celebrity boxing one on Instagram with
your Instagram Chris
you can plug it you should plug it what
do you mean plug I say it doesn't have a
plug to plug in Jimmy hold on Chris
bagel boss Morgan and Instagram hope you
want to follow you course Morgan just
write it I know I'm not saying I'm not a
stupid [ __ ] I'm jumping him look
stupid
what are you to email me one more Jim
and Sam catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the SiriusXM adage